up next is Anna in Indiana and a welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi thank you
quick questions my jobs being furloughed
April 20th through May 3rd and will
receive unemployment for that we should
cover my regular pay but I used to dress
like this until the whole cylinder virus
now just something comfortable before
they announce a furlough I was thinking
of working at Papa John's is delivering
pizzas now I don't know if I do that how
will inspector I'm playing that and if
it's even worth it or if I should just
wait until after a furlough son do you
know what you'll be receiving yet an
unemployment I don't they said that with
the night recover it I make about $500 a
week so the unemployment and then I
guess there's like an extra $600 to
compensate for the difference an extra
$600 yeah you're talking about caring
yes she's talking about the this and
this two trillion dollar plan is that
they're gonna give $600 an additional
unemployment insurance
yeah all right and so you can even make
a thousand dollars doing nothing or you
can work and make $2,000 if you were
delivering pizzas in two weeks
oh I thought you're making 500 a week
right now I'm making 500 a week it's
only a part-time job so I don't know if
I would make more than what I make now
or if the wood would work out or the
typical pizza delivery person is making
1,500 to 2,000 dollars working four
nights a week a month okay and you could
do that during the day and stock shelves
at the grocery store or do that at night
stock shelves during the grocery store
and you end up making more than this
with unemployment though you're not
allowed to make more than half of your
unemployment in addition to the
unemployment without disqualifying
yourself from taking the unemployment
check so if you're willing to work a lot
you're going to make three times as much
as you would with on with taking
unemployment and vitami if you want to
sit at home
do that for a thousand but he hung with
me I'm working I want more money you
know and I think there's plenty of
opportunities for not just delivering
pizzas all kinds napa tractor supply is
hiring targets hiring its la Mart's
hiring thousand undred thousand jobs
with amazon right now tractor supply
just posted five thousand jobs you know
I just mentioned them they're great
company there's I mean all the pizza
places are hiring all the grocery store
chains are hiring every one of them and
so these aren't necessarily jobs you
want but you were already working a
part-time gig for five hundred bucks a
week and so you know it's not a lot
different than what you were doing and
so I don't know sure what your furlough
really means it may just mean you never
go back you know I'll just add this
little anecdote she has to figure this
out for herself David you and I've been
coming in we haven't missed the you know
we're essential so we get to come in and
all this good stuff and we've got to
scale back crew obviously but I've
talked to some friends who have been at
home and they're jonesing to get out of
the house so I don't think staying at
home is all it's cracked up to be I
think the human spirit wants to do
something and to the point we just made
that she can make more money and come
out of this thing in better financial
shape why wouldn't you take that
opportunity that's what I would push you
to do is challenge you to consider that
they put you in a weird situation yeah I
just got you got to decide but I think
there's plenty of work to be done right
now and I don't think there's any reason
for you to go hungry either way so good
question